(Man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We urge you to catch
this golden opportunity
before Pat and I
knock it out of the park.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
I want to be involved
with this.
I think you're gonna hit
a home run with this.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
So I'm gonna give you
ten seconds, Chris.
Before you do that--
I am not gonna let
this price go up.
Oh, he's pulling
an old Mark Cuban.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I absolutely hate
to see young entrepreneurs
Getting completely screwed.
It's sink...
What is it
we don't know yet?
Or swim.
You just got on board
as an opportunist.
She's not stupid.
I think they call me
a mini shark.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First up is Jenny Nigrosh,
who believes she can make
the sharks a lot of green with
her environmentally friendly
business.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jennie Nigrosh.
I'm president
of the green garmento,
and I'm here
seeking $300,000
for 20% equity
in my growing business.
How many of you have ever had to
struggle with a twist tie
or search for clothing that was
suffocating inside plastic?
You're not alone.
Every year, U.S. dry cleaners
process 1.4 billion
items of clothing,
creating an estimated
300 million pounds
of single-use plastic
that invade our landfills
and waterways,
threatening our marine life,
including sharks...
(laughs)
And wildlife,
including Mr. Wonderful.
(laughter)
The green garmento has
multi functions
to help you create a cleaner
closet and a cleaner planet.
When you get the bag home,
simply turn it upside-Down.
It'll hang from
any hook in your house.
And it's
a space-Saving hamper,
or it'll fit
into a hamper frame.
Throw your dry cleaning in.
When you're ready
to go to the cleaner,
simply cinch the bag,
carry it like a duffel
or a yoga bag,
bring it to
your dry cleaner
and ask for them
to save the bag,
keep it with your clothes.
And when you get
your clothes returned,
the bag has magically morphed
into this gorgeous
hanging garment bag,
and your clothes are hanging
gently inside,
and not a single-use
plastic bag in sight.
Sharks, sometimes the biggest
ideas truly are the simplest.
Please help the world
to be fantastic,
use less plastic,
and invest
in the green garmento.
Cool idea.
How do I make money?
Right now
dry cleaning packaging
is about a $200 million
a year business.
This month, we're gonna reach
our million-dollar mark
in sales.
Whoa.
What about
the last 12 months?
Just this year,
we're at about $260,000.
We have projected
just under $400,000.
Do I pay for the bag
as the consumer,
or does the dry cleaning shop
pay for it?
Depends where
you're buying it.
Most likely, you'd buy it
from your dry cleaner,
and they buy it from us.
Do you sell
to dry cleaners?
We sell to dry cleaners
all over the country.
What do you sell 'it for?
Um, they are in the $4 range,
and then we print
their logos on them.
So we also--We do mostly
customized bags.
What do they cost you
to make?
There's two things my mama
never told me to talk about,
and that's my age and how much
my bags cost. (chuckles)
No. Come on now.
How are we gonna know?
You can't hold that back.
But did mama tell you you ain't
gonna get an investment?
(laughs) And my mama's
from Boston,
so it's weird
that she'd talk like that.
Um...
(laughs)
They are under $2.
Do they charge me more...
no.
As opposed to plastic?
Which is exactly what
my dry cleaner did.
He came out with these bags,
and I keep losing them.
And every time I lose them,
they charge me money for it.
Okay.
Is--Is that one of the models
that people are using?
That's not normally what
we would like to have happen.
First of all, your dry cleaner
Should be giving you free bags
because you're Mr. Herjavec,
but...
that's True.
Um, the, uh...
(laughs) No, he should be...
well, here's the other
problem, Jennie--
Charging you double
is what he should be doing.
But are--Robert, are you
saying this actually
had happened to you?
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
Yep.
Here's the problem
when I looked into it--
Most dry cleaners
are relatively small.
Mm-hmm.
So they don't actually do
the dry cleaning at the shop.
Mm-hmm.
The problem was, they said,
actually sorting.
The idea of you bringing
your own bag
and them having to put
your stuff
in your bag
was too much time for them.
These plastic bags,
however,
are costing them
5 to 15 cents each.
So the sale
is to the dry cleaner,
and your pitch to them is,
"you're actually
gonna save money"?
if one person rotates
their two bags per year,
that is a $35- to $45-Saving
on just the one--
And they pocket that margin?
They keep that money?
Absolutely.
Yes.
And then they resale these.
These bags retail
on our web site for $9.99.
But currently now
how many competitors
do you have
and how big are they
in relevance to you?
One, really.
It's a totally different bag.
They aren't at all
consumer-driven.
We also have the patent
on these bags.
We have 18 claims
in a utility patent.
I love a clear bag.
Mm-hmm.
I could look in my closet
and see exactly
what I'm pulling out...
Right.
Without opening a bag
to see what's inside--One.
And secondly, I covet
these little plastic bags
and save them
for when I travel because...
seriously?
I find if I group--
Because the clothing wrinkles
without the use of the bag.
So if you were to put
a man's suit, a woman's dress...
Right.
And a pair of trousers in there
without the plastic
on each one,
they will wrinkle.
It's true. Men's suits, if you
put the plastic between them,
don't wrinkle.
I never knew that.
(Kevin) Yeah, it's true.
Our bags are breathable.
Would you rather
search through that
or would you rather have
your stuff neatly hanging?
Jennie, can we focus
on the numbers for a second?
Sure.
You say you're gonna make
$400,000 this year.
After you pay yourself
a normalized salary,
how much money will be
at the bottom line?
We are not in profit yet.
Who is "We"?
Oh, my husband and I. We run
the business together. Um--
So on $400,000 in sales,
you're not making any money?
Correct.
(Daymond) Ooh.
We are not--
Why?
It's a brand-New category.
Uh, it is a new business.
You know, we're just
four years in,
and to have--
four years?
You haven't made any money
in four years?
Um...
Well, we've made sales.
But you haven't made
any money.
How much did you lose
this year?
How much will you lose
on $400,000?
We probably l-Lose
about $10,000 a month or so.
A month? A month?
(Daymond) Whoa.
How much did you lose
last year?
to be honest, I don't know
the answer to that.
You're supposed to know how much
you're making or losing.
I know I'm supposed to now
my numbers cold.
I read your article. Um...
(laughs)
I did, because--
You didn't--You didn't take it
to heart. Yeah.
Because I didn't know you
were gonna ask me that.
(Kevin) Really, I have--
I have a--
I honestly--
How much money have you
put in over four years?
'cause we're about to ask
how much debt is on it.
We--We put in about
$380,000 of our own money.
Your money?
Actually, we have
non-Equity investors.
Non-Equity investors?
What do they get?
What are they doing,
lending you money?
They are getting, um...
debt?
A 9% revenue
until they're paid back.
That's brutal.
So you're paying 9% of
your revenue off the top?
Correct.
Okay, and how much did they
give you to get that 9%?
We raised, um,
about $900,000.
Ohh!
$900,000?
(Robert) wow.
You're in for $1.26 million.
Aha.
(Barbara) It gets worse.
Why do we have to pull
that out of you?!
♪♪
So you're paying 9% of
your revenue off the top?
Correct.
Okay, and how much did they
give you to get that 9%?
We raised,
um, about $900,000.
Ohh!
$900,000?
You're in for $1.26 million.
Aha.
(Barbara) It gets worse.
Why do we have to
pull that out of you?!
um, it's a little
overwhelming up here.
I'm not gonna lie.
Mm.
No, it gets worse.
Okay, how much of the $900,000
have you paid back?
Not very much.
It's very--It's--
Not that much.
How are you going to
find the capital
to dig your way out
of this monster hole?
It's not really
a monster hole,
because every single day...
it's $900,000.
(Robert) Sure, it is.
Jennie, let me ask you this,
how much gross sales
do you have to generate
to pay those people back?
Um... (exhales)
I...
these people trusted in you
and gave you $900,000.
It is a risk,
and we are paying 9% on--
Jennie, it's--
It's a great product,
and you're growing the business,
which I love.
But there was an elephant
in the room,
and we had to find it.
Okay.
I'm out.
(Barbara)
May I say something?
Sure.
I think the product's
very well-designed, very clever.
Thank you.
But it would just be like buying
into a problem, honestly.
So I'm out.
Okay.
(Kevin) You know,
the trouble with green,
it doesn't work unless there's
an economic reason.
People fundamentally
want to save the planet,
unless it costs them
something.
That's the cold, hard truth.
Mm-hmm.
That's why solar doesn't work
and that's why wind
doesn't work,
and this is why
this isn't working.
I'm out.
You learned
an expensive lesson, Jennie.
You know, one of the things
that entrepreneurs
always talk about is,
"if I only had the money,"
but debt is not your friend.
I-it's just a trap a lot
of entrepreneurs fall into.
Right.
And I'm out.
Okay.
It's a very intimidating room,
and...
I don't want to beat you up
for what you did
to start your business because
you didn't know any better.
You may have
just had a-a passion,
you wanted to get it started.
But your business turned,
unfortunately,
instead of cleaning bags,
into a body bag.
(chuckles)
I'm out.
Okay. All right.
Good luck, Jennie.
(Barbara) Thank you.
(Daymond) Thank you.
Good luck.
All right. Thank you.
It is definitely overwhelming,
and I did literally feel like
I was being circled
by the sharks.
If there's one thing I can tell
future entrepreneurs,
know... thy... numbers.
In season 1, Tiffany Krumins
made a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for her children's
medicine dispenser
Ava the elephant.
You know what? I'd love
to take your offer.
I'm so happy. We're gonna make
money on this together.
Let's see
what she's up to now.
♪♪
I walked into the shark tank
with a clay prototype.
Since then I've sold
100,000 units,
with over $1 million
in sales.
♪♪
Today's a very exciting day.
We're launching
our second product--
The Ava the elephant
thermometer stickers.
I'm going back to my very own
elementary school
to launch the product
in the entire school district.
Do you guys like to have
your temperature taken?
(children) No!
Ava the elephant
thermometer stickers
Are liquid-Crystal
technology stickers
that you place
on your child's forehead,
and it reads their temperature.
This year we're expecting
$1 million in sales
from just the sticker alone.
What's going on
with the web site?
I know you have
the rough draft for me.
It's looking really good.
It's got all of our colors.
It used to just be
Barbara and I,
and now I work
with a logistics company,
over 30 people,
four international distributors.
I can't believe how far
Ava the elephant has come
in the last three years.
♪♪
A few months after the show,
I was diagnosed
with thyroid cancer.
The success of the business
really helped us financially,
and the process itself has been
really therapeutic for me
and helped me
get through that.
I'm very thankful
for "Shark tank"
For giving me this opportunity
to--to face that challenge.
(children)
Thank you, "Shark tank"!
♪♪
I'm Pat Pezet...
and I'm Matt Canepa.
And we live
in San Francisco, California.
And we are the owner
of grinds.
We met in college and played
baseball together there.
I was a second baseman,
and Matt was a catcher.
(laughs)
Get out!
(Matt) After my junior year,
I got drafted by a pro team
and played three years
of baseball
before heading back
to San Francisco.
Great job, guys.
Having played baseball
for a number of years,
you begin to realize
how prevalent
chewing tobacco is
and how unhealthy
and really disgusting it is.
So Matt and I got together
and decided
to do something about that.
We created this product
that helps people
stop using tobacco.
It's a product
baseball players love.
We know that it's got
huge potential
outside
and in much broader markets.
We need an investment
from the sharks
to take our great product
and put it on retail shelves
across the U.S.
The sharks will take
one look at our business
and see the two guys
behind it,
and realize they've got
a home run.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Pat.
And I'm Matt.
And our company is Grinds.
And we're here today seeking
a $75,000 investment
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Our product,
grinds coffee pouches,
are filled
with freshly ground coffee
that's been flavored
and supplemented
with B vitamins
and other important nutrients
to keep you bright
and alert
while providing a healthy
alternative to chewing tobacco.
Our product has
a unique opportunity
to capitalize
and gain market share
in three of the most lucrative
markets in the world--
Tobacco, coffee, and energy.
And as former players
ourselves,
we spent the past two years
building our brand
through our contacts in both
major and minor league baseball
with over 20 major league teams
currently using the product,
including the Chicago Cubs
and Boston Red Sox.
In the U.S. alone,
chewing tobacco is
a $4.5 billion-a-year industry.
It is estimated that over
half of all users
make at least one attempt
to quit their habit.
With your help and experience,
we can take our product
into every gas station
and convenience store,
not only in the U.S.,
but in the world.
So, sharks, we urge you
to catch this golden opportunity
before Pat and I...
knock it out of the park.
(bat cracks ball)
(Barbara chuckles)
So before hand out some samples,
we'll give you a quick demo
in case you're not familiar
with how to use the product.
Open it up,
take out a pouch or two,
place it in your mouth.
Let it sit for 20 minutes,
half-hour, 45 minutes--
Whatever you need
to get your energy kick.
When you're done,
take it out, throw it away.
And that's it.
So now Matt's gonna pass out
our best seller--
The mint chocolate flavor
that you guys can all try.
And then we've got
the cinnamon roll and mocha
that you can open up and try
or check out the aroma.
(sniffs) whoa.
So you can put it kinda
right in your cheek.
You don't actually
Chew on it.
Okay, so this is starting
to work now.
I can taste the chocolaty...
(both) Yeah.
(Kevin) Coffee thing going here.
That's the idea.
How--How long
will the pouch last?
It can go up to 45 minutes
or so as well. I mean, it's--
How much coffee equivalent
in one pouch?
So one pouch is about
a quarter cup of coffee.
But one can has got
about 20 pouches,
which is four or five
cups of coffee.
One is just a quarter cup?
'cause I gotta tell you, it--
it feels a lot stronger.
It's strong. Yeah, Yeah.
Yeah, right.
So wait. How'd you guys
get into this?
So Matt and I met
at Cal Poly.
We were both
business finance students
playing baseball together.
Matt was a catcher.
He was actually drafted
by the Chicago Cubs.
We were working
on this econ project,
and we were procrastinating,
as most college students do.
We, uh, ended up not having
much in our pantries late night,
and we needed some sort
of energy kick.
So what did we do?
We actually took
coffee grounds--
Regular just coffee grounds--
And put it in our mouth.
Ew!
So after ten minutes or so,
we look at each other.
We kind of smile and we say,
"Yeah, we kind of feel
an energy kick,"
but we got all these coffee
grounds all over our teeth--
And we just started
brainstorming right away.
And we said, "why don't we
come up with a prototype?"
Next thing we knew, there was
a flyer on our campus...
Yeah.
That said, "Have a cool idea?
Free pizza."
So being starving
college students...
(Robert laughs)
Yeah, we went down,
filled out a questionnaire.
Next thing you knew,
we were pitching
at a business plan
competition,
had some seed money,
And, uh, and launched
our product at spring training.
So do you have sales today?
So in 2010 we did $3,500.
Matt and I were thinking at
the end of the baseball season,
it's time to get
a 9-to-5 job.
Two days after
the San Francisco Giants
won the world Series,
we got a call from
their manager Bruce Bochy.
He said, "guys, I've been
using your product.
It might be saving my life.
I wish you guys the best."
(singsongy) Bingo!
We took that as the kick
in the pants to say,
"All right, we gotta make
this product meet the idea."
And we proceeded to find
new manufacturing,
raised a little bit
of financing.
So basically last year in 2011,
we did $135,000.
And this year we are on track to
do $300,000 by--By year's end.
Wow.
So tell us about
the cost issues.
For retail,
direct to consumer,
we--We like to offer the cans
at about $3.99.
Is that equivalent to what
tobaccy would cost?
Tobacco can range from,
on the low side, $3.50,
to up to $7 with taxes.
What are you gonna sell it
to distribution for?
$2.69 per can.
And what do you make it for?
Last year the cost per can
was $1.30.
This year, it's been around
$1.24, $1.25.
And we're hoping to drop it
at least below $1.10
by the end of the year.
(Barbara) Hey, Matt and Pat,
I love your energy.
I think you have great energy.
I can't imagine you not selling
this product, frankly.
I get it.
But it's just not a product
that I can relate to--
Chewing something in my mouth
like this--So I'm out.
Hey, guys, you're--You're
creating a new category, okay?
And this is wonderful,
and you got a lot of energy,
and it's smart.
But one of the problems is,
coffee companies
have a lot of coffee.
If you prove out this category,
why wouldn't they crush you
like the cockroaches
you are right now?
What you need is capital.
You need money to fire it up,
and you gotta get
into retail faster.
You don't want to wait until
the coffee guys figure it out
and come after you.
You want to get the brand out
in every store you possibly can.
You need money.
Why don't I provide you
with $100,000?
And the way
you pay me back is,
every time you sell a tin,
you give me a quarter.
I'm gonna make it easy.
I'm not gonna ask
for any equity at all.
Maybe I'm your guy.
I'm your bank.
Perhaps, yeah.
(Daymond) Are you looking for
solely capital?
Or are you looking for
the strategic relationship?
Strategic relationship.
The strategic relationship
is of course valuable to us.
We know baseball, we know our
product, we know the numbers.
Distribution
is that missing link.
And we're doing our homework,
But someone who can
expedite that process--
Pat, honestly, I know
nothing about chewing tobacco.
But I want to be involved
with this.
I think you're gonna hit
a home run with this.
I'll give you the $75,000
for... 15%,
but I really would like Daymond
in on the deal with me.
Not because I need the money,
but I think he can do
the distribution.
I mean, that's his specialty.
I'm okay with Robert on that
because this is
such a good deal,
and you guys--
You guys know your stuff.
So what exactly
are you offering here?
So $75,000,
37.5 from each of us,
for 15%.
Why give up so much now
when in a year, after I help
you get distribution,
it'll be worth ten times more?
And I won't take any equity.
That's why they call me
Mr. Wonderful.
I know what you need
and when you need it.
Yeah, you're definitely
correct in that sense.
I-I don't think we're--
Of course I'm correct.
Why give up any equity?
Mark, do you--
Mark, mark,
do you have anything
you'd like to add
to the conversation?
(laughs)
Look, guys,
in any sport, you can
play small or you can go big.
I see
tobacco replacement products
as a medium-Sized industry.
I see you guys carving out
a nice niche.
But like I always say,
you know,
the most valuable asset I need
to get a return on is my time.
And the return on time
just isn't there.
So for that reason, I'll make it
easier for these guys,
and I'll go out.
Okay.
Daymond and Robert,
would you guys be willing to
up the cash to $100,000
for 15% equity
and go in on the deal 50-50?
Would you be willing
to up the equity?
'cause that's all I was
gonna say as well.
It'd be--It'd be hard
to do that without more cash.
Guys, I'm not gonna do it.
And I'll tell you why
I'm not gonna do it.
With what I'm bringing
to the table,
the $25,000 is neither
here nor there.
Over the long run,
the $25,000 is not gonna
make the difference.
Yeah, you're step--
You're stepping over dollars
to save pennies right now.
I absolutely hate to see
young entrepreneurs
Getting completely screwed.
Why give up any equity?
I'm staying at the $75,000--
$37,500 from the 2 of us--
For 15%.
I'm gonna stay with that.
It's equity versus a royalty.
What are you going to do?
(speaks inaudibly)
♪♪
Daymond and Robert, we'd--
Wait.
We've accepted your deal.
Ah!
All right.
(Robert) Home run.
Thanks, guys. Thanks.
We're excited.
Looking forward
to working with you guys.
Thank you, man.
(Robert) All right, great job.
We got our international/
National distributor partners.
Couldn't be more excited.
Pretty jacked up about it.
Pretty jacked up about it
right now.
Yeah.
♪♪
Next up are Scott Duff
and Carlos Ortiz,
who believe the sharks
can put some heat
into their currently cold
business.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Carlos Ortiz.
And I'm Scott Duff.
Together, we're my cold snap,
and we're here seeking $50,000
for 100% stake in our company,
plus 12% royalty
on future sales.
Huh?
(Barbara) 100%?
There you go. It's like Kevin's
book of entrepreneurship.
We've got a--We've got
a great deal for you guys,
but more importantly,
we've got a great product
to share with you.
Scott, let's say that you find
yourself by a pool or on a boat
and you wanna
keep your drinks cold.
How would you keep
those cool?
I'd use an ice chest.
Okay.
Now you're ready to enjoy
one of those drinks.
You take it out
of your ice chest
into the hot summer sun.
How would you go about
trying to keeping those cool?
My cold snap--The only Ice chest
that fits in your hand.
Guys, my cold snap works
because it leverages
the simplest process.
It's just ice and water
in a cup.
He takes the drink out of
his ice chest in the sun,
he simply slides it
into his cold snap,
he Seals it all together
with Our Leak-Proof ring...
(clicking)
And now he has an ice chest
that fits in his hand.
His last sip will literally be
as cold as his first.
(can fizzes)
Right now, we're looking for
a fast-swimming shark
who can take my cold snap
to the next level.
Who's it gonna be?
So you wanna get $50,000
from us...
yes.
And we would own 100%
of the patent or property.
Mm-hmm.
And we would pay you
a 12% royalty.
Correct.
So you basically want us to
work for you.
(laughs)
Well...
well, if you take 100%
of the company,
you will be doing that part.
Now because the important part
has been done--
The important part
Would've been
that you have
a large amount of sales.
A quarter of a million.
Is that done?
A quarter of a million
have been sold.
How did you sell them?
In the promotional products
industry.
And, uh, they g--They paid us
a licensing fee at that time,
and it was 10%.
(Robert)
so you've already got sales.
Is that deal over?
Yes, it is. It's over.
That deal is over.
What happened to that deal?
Well, we struck
that deal with
the largest promotional company
in the United States.
Unfortunately,
unbeknownst to us,
that company was going
under bankruptcy.
So they really actually
mismanaged the product.
There's inventory sitting
in Houston, waiting to be sold.
How much inventory?
We have 20,000 units
of inventory.
20,000 units of inventory.
Mm-hmm.
How much does each unit cost?
Uh, they cost a little bit
over a dollar to make.
Can we see a couple of units,
please?
Yeah, absolutely.
(Robert) So, Carlos,
my dad always told me,
if it's too good to be true,
it's too good to be true.
You've licensed it. You've
created it. You've got sales.
I mean, why aren't you doing
the heavy lifting?
(Daymond) You don't have
too many sales
'cause he still has inventory,
Robert.
Why are you telling us that
you can't sell your own product?
What is it we don't know yet
and we're gonna find out
in two seconds?
No, Kevin, we're not. Before
when it was launched prior,
we didn't not own the tooling.
In order to get it to
the promotional products
industry, we spent $200,000.
And it augmented us
pretty inefficiently.
What did you spend
the $200,000 on?
We--We went to mexico.
We--We did prototypes first.
We did tooling,
uh, worked on the patent.
You didn't spend the money well.
We had attorneys for the --
We didn't
spend the money well.
We spent it in a--
We spent it very poorly.
And how much revenue
have you gotten back
through your licensing
and any other efforts?
We got 10 cents, uh,
10 cents per Unit.
(Robert) What was
the total dollar you got?
What was--
We got $25,000 from that time.
That's all you've made?
Mm-hmm. Yeah, during that--
Yeah, from promotional Products,
that's all we made.
That's correct.
How long ago did
the other company go bankrupt?
This was in 2000...
2004.
So it's been sitting around
forever then.
(Scott speaks indistinctly)
It's been sitting around
for a little bit.
(Robert) Oh, I thought
this was, like, now.
So you haven't been able to sell
those units?
(Scott and Carlos
speak indistinctly)
No, no, no,
this is getting nasty, guys,
no, no, no, Daymond, Daymond,
maybe we're not doing
a good job communicating.
You're doing a horrible job,
don't worry about it, okay?
(mark laughs)
it--There was a period
of inactivity. We--We...
eight years. Eight years.
(Scott speaks indistinctly)
(Robert) What did you do
in the eight years, Scott?
Well...
well--
You put it on ice, right?
(mark, Barbara,
and Robert laugh)
We didn't put it on pause,
and I'll tell you why.
So we stopped for a little bit.
We had spent $200,000.
Now we're a little bit older,
a little bit Wiser,
and have a little bit more
powder in our--In our storage.
So we were relaunching,
and we recognized
the opportunity that
you guys could accomplish.
So this, for me, feels like
you took a cold body
out of the closet,
you're wheeling it back in,
you want us to buy in.
If you're not excited about
running your business...
(speaks indistinctly)
(chuckles) I can't get excited.
Barbara, Barbara,
I'm--I'm sorry that we gave--
I'm sorry that we gave
that--That--That--
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Barbara, it--
It's not a cold body.
It--Well...
Okay, so, you guys,
now--Now you've actually
created more confusion
because you just spent
$20,000 more
to get 20,000 units
of inventory.
Mm-hmm.
Why?
Because today, we have the time,
we have the resources.
And we are fully committed.
Believe me, there's nobody
that's more committed to this--
you can't--You are not
fully committed to a product
where you're saying,
"We're just gonna give you
the company for $50,000."
I don't have a problem
with the approach.
What I have a problem with
is this thing died years ago,
and now you're trying
to pawn it off on us.
It--It didn't die.
It was a dead business
years ago.
Our goal--Carlos and I's goal
is--is to move this thing
forward.
We think it has
tremendous potential.
Scott, never invest
in a business
that's rolling downhill,
'cause a boulder rolling
downhill cannot be stopped.
I'm out.
Okay. Let--Let--Let me say...
I'm just trying
to figure out,
can I make any money
off this thing?
I don't think so.
I think the problems
are really dramatic
in terms of how you get it
to the market.
I don't think the beer business
or the pop business
or any bottler's gonna
add to the cost
of distributing their product
when They've already got sales.
They're gonna have
no interest.
So I gotta sell it
one at a time.
I have no interest
in joining you in that hell.
I am out.
Okay.
(Daymond)
You're asking for 12% royalty.
So in this market,
a royalty at 12%--
I could probably go get
Mickey mouse as a license
and put it on anything
and sell a large amount of it.
So for something unknown,
you should be asking for 5%.
That's just the beginning
of the problems
of something you haven't proven
in the market. I'm out.
Before we continue
with any--
This--This boulder
that's rolling,
let's get off the royalties.
Really, what we want--
Well, that's not working so far,
is it?
Well... Well...
guys, I'd like to--
I'd like to stop it.
(mark and Daymond laugh)
Uh...
hard to stop a boulder.
I'm--I'm trying. I'm trying.
The problem is,
I don't like it,
I don't want it,
I don't need it,
and I definitely don't want
to help it.
So...
(tears paper)
I'm out.
(Mark) Thanks, guys.
Thanks for your time.
♪♪
Do you think the Champagne
they brought is for us?
(laughs)
(Kevin)
I was just looking at that.
I think it's very cool
right now.
(plastic scrapes)
You know what?
There's nothing in it.
(Robert) Really?
(laughs)
Just like this deal, it's empty.
(both laugh)
♪♪
In season 2,
Rebecca Rescate pitched
her cat toilet training system
citikitty...
you take the citikitty training
seat that you see there,
you put it on your toilet,
and you fill it with
a small amount of kitty litter.
And sealed a deal
with Kevin Harrington...
20%, $100,000?
Yes.
Okay.
Which catapulted her business
to huge success.
Before "Shark tank,"
citikitty had only $100,000
in sales a year,
and now citikitty is breaking
$1 million this year alone.
Now she's back to the tank
to try her luck again
with a partner
and a brand-new product.
She's so familiar.
Oh, yeah.
Hello, sharks. I'm Chris.
And I'm Rebecca.
Our product is Hoodie Pillow.
We're seeking $90,000
for 15% of our company.
Sharks, you may remember me
and my product from season 2,
the citikitty
cat toilet training kit.
Not only did I walk away
from "Shark Tank" with a deal,
but my experience helped me see
the huge potential
in my newest venture,
Hoodie Pillow.
Citikitty revolutionized
owning a cat.
Get ready for Hoodie Pillow
to revolutionize relaxation.
Americans love hoodies Because
they provide casual comfort
wherever you go.
You put your hood on,
you zip it up,
and you're in your own
cozy environment.
We love our hoodies so much,
we would wear them
every chance we could.
But at times,
they become impractical.
When lying down,
they pull at your neck,
and when sleeping,
the sweatshirt gets too hot.
And really, the best part
about them is just the hood.
Problem solved
with Hoodie Pillow.
Hoodie Pillow combines
the comfort of your pillow
with America's favorite
piece of clothing...
Oh, you're kidding me.
(Kevin laughs)
the hoodie.
(Robert laughs)
The hood is completely attached
to the pillowcase.
There's no pulling.
There's no discomfort.
It allows you
to turn your head
and sink into your comfy spot
with ease.
Our design has
adjustable drawstrings
that block out light
and dampen sound,
a convenient pocket
for your phone and tv remote,
or a porthole that keeps
your headphones tangle-free.
Daymond, why don't you come on
down and give it a try?
I'll give a shot. You know,
I made some money off of hoods.
I'm gonna lay down...
you're gonna lay down
and put the hood on.
(Kevin)
Stick your head in it.
(all laughing)
(Robert) Ohh.
I-I don't think he can look
more ridiculous.
(all laugh)
Or more relaxed.
Right now for Hoodie Pillow,
we've already sold
over 3,000 units.
We launched eight weeks ago.
All right.
(Mark) That's your market.
(laughter continues)
(nasal voice)
Can I get into the club?
(laughter continues)
All right.
(Kevin) Hey, Rebecca,
you had...
(Rebecca) You know what?
Let--Let's call it
like it is.
You had a Winner in
the cat, uh, poo-poo dome thing.
There was no question
about it.
Citikitty is doing fantastic.
We're gonna reach
about $5 million in sales
this coming year.
$5 million?!
Good for you.
Did you invent this?
Chris is the inventor
of this product.
And as soon as I saw it,
I knew the huge market potential
for it.
There was a reason that
the snuggie sold $500 million
in product.
(Kevin) So you just got on board
as an opportunist?
I think they call me
a mini shark.
(chuckles) A mini shark.
I own 30% of the company.
How much did you put up?
$15,000.
Chris--Christopher, how did you
come up with it?
I invented Hoodie Pillow
After bringing my triplet girls
home from the hospital.
Our lives were turned
upside down,
our sleep schedules were
completely taken away from us,
and I needed a way to shut
the world off just a little bit
and regroup.
I've known Rebecca
for a few years,
and she was one of the first
people that it brought it to.
And you should've seen
the look on her face.
So, Rebecca, you have a knack
for crazy-looking stuff.
Yes.
But you were right last time.
I gotta tell you,
when you came out here,
I thought it was the most
ridiculous thing I'd ever seen,
and your proved us all wrong.
I have the same reaction here.
Yeah.
Well, you have
to keep in mind,
we launched Hoodie Pillow
eight weeks ago--
A soft launch with one Link
on facebook--
And we did $60,000
in 8 weeks.
I invested in, uh, Chris
and in this product
'cause I believe in it.
Chris and I--on our, uh--
but you already have a shark,
one of our beloved sharks,
who helped you with this
progress--Kevin Harrington--
Yep.
Of your citikitty.
You have money.
You have distribution.
I came here thinking that
your experience in textiles...
Yeah.
And then the experience that
Barbara has with consumer--
(Robert) I know why she's here.
(Rebecca) It's different.
Because "Shark tank" made
citikitty a $5 million product.
She's not stupid.
Maybe, Chris,
you can answer this.
One of you are gonna have to.
You put your money
in a valuation
of around $50,000
for the business.
Then you walk in here
and tell me it's worth $600,000.
Rebecca invested in the company
when it was an idea.
We launched the product.
We had sales.
It's proving that people like
this product.
They see it and they buy it.
We posted one link on facebook.
The product went viral.
Within three weeks, we were
on "Good Morning America,"
"today" Show, aol, msn,
yahoo's main pages,
nasdaq "Businessweek."
People see it and they buy it.
Rebecca, here's where
I was wrong about citikitty.
It fixed a problem.
Yes.
People didn't have to clean
Kitty litter.
What problem is this solving?
It doesn't matter.
There are 30 million students
in colleges
that are sitting in dorm rooms
right now
that are laying within 4 feet
of somebody else
that love the hoodie Pillow.
And all looking to buy--Spend
their money on something stupid.
Right?
Yeah. It's only 20 bucks.
And what does it cost
to make it?
It costs us $5 to make one.
Is there a patent on this?
We have utility
and a design patent on this.
Nobody can put a Hood
on a pillowcase or a Pillow.
(laughs) That just sounds
so ridiculous.
(laughs) Yeah.
But you know what?
I knew, like, with citikitty,
that I could sell
maybe $10 million,
$15 million worth of goods.
But this product?
This is totally different.
We're talking
tens of millions of dollars.
Tens of millions?
Absolutely.
There are 300 million americans,
like, that this product
is applicable to.
It's anybody
with a head that sleeps,
and I'm pretty sure
that's every one of you.
(laughter)
And what are you gonna do
with the $90,000?
First, we're gonna start
investing in, um,
low-cost high-yield marketing.
What low-cost high-yield
marketing?
Uh, well,
a lot of social marketing
and stuff like that online,
facebook.
We posted a video, like,
two or three weeks ago
that have already had, like,
10,000 views
and have driven a ton of traffic
to our web site.
After that, we're gonna start
running a commercial
that we've already produced
and tested.
So you're not using any of this
for production
or anything of that nature?
(mouths word)
You have production
already locked up?
Yes.
We do have a new product.
Hoodie Pillow has
a huge market for it,
but the more exciting thing is,
there are 1.5 billion people
that fly on airlines
every year.
(laughs) Oh, god!
(Robert laughs)
(Mark) Actually,
that's not bad.
You know what? That's not bad.
Could you bundle that together
and sell 'em together?
(Rebecca) Of course.
The reason I like that
is it solves a problem.
Yes.
I don't want to talk
to the person next to me
on the airplane.
Tell us--Tell us about
this one.
Okay, so there are
1.5 billion people
that fly on airlines
every single year.
And most of us are sitting
in a commercial aircraft.
We don't have
our own 757s or g5s.
We're flying, sitting within
1, 2 feet of somebody else.
Hoodie Pillow provides you
comfort by holding up your neck
when you're trying to relax,
and then also provides you
privacy.
The travel Pillow retails
for $15
and, uh, the cost is
less than $3 to make it.
You have pretty good credibility
in this space.
Even though the stuff may
be crap, you sell a lot of it.
That's what matters.
(chuckles) Well, thank you.
So here's an offer for you.
I'll make it very simple.
Um, I'll give you the 90k,
but I'm gonna be
a 1/3, third partner.
But the only way
I would do this deal
is that you don't take
any draw from the business,
and when you make the draw
you'll decide.
But each of us pay ourselves
the same amount
when the draw occurs.
Look at her.
She's already laughing at him.
Well, maybe she is,
maybe she isn't.
But right now
you haven't made any offers.
So when it comes time to
cash out, I wanna wet my beak
at the same pace you are.
I'm hearing "Cash out."
That's all I'm hearing.
I'm not hearing something
that's gonna help us grow this
business is what we're...
I don't want to help you grow
the business.
I don't want
to help finance it.
I just know that you're
very successful at what you do.
I don't know.
At least be respectful.
You may not get another offer,
so you should be careful.
Yeah.
Yes, you're right. Um...
(laughs)
(Kevin) Yes, I am.
I'm always right.
Oh, wow.
Um... we'll consider it.
You decide when
the capital comes out.
But when it comes out,
each of us get a third,
a third, a third.
What's wrong with that?
Nothing.
Kevin, I would be interested
in working with you.
I like you a lot.
You're my favorite shark.
I would be willing to do...
25% for $100,000.
I wanna be a third,
a third, a third,
and I'm happy giving you 90k.
I like my offer.
I'd to hear if there are
other offers.
I mean, I think we're bringing
a lot to the table here.
We have a product that has
a huge market.
I'm--I'm just like Kevin.
I want--I want a third
of the company.
I don't care about
pulling the money out like that
necessarily.
If you guys are working
every day, I'm fine with that.
And I wanna take this to my guys
at travelpro,
and I wanna take that
to hsn
and--And help with
the manufacturing.
Can you make the decision
and give me in ten seconds?
Or I'm gonna be out.
♪♪
Can you make the decision
and give me in ten seconds?
Or I'm gonna be out.
Before you do that--No--
because I'm very excited,
and I'm not gonna
let this price go up.
No, no, I just wanna
jump in with Daymond.
Daymond--
I'm not gonna
let the price go up.
So I'm gonna give you
ten seconds, Chris and Rebecca,
to please accept my offer,
'cause I'm excited, and I do not
want this price to go up.
Oh, he's pulling
the ol' Mark Cuban.
I think the--one of
the amazing things is
actually hearing what
all of the sharks have to say,
and we haven't even gotten
that opportunity yet.
We haven't heard anything
from Mr. Cuban or...
okay, the ten seconds is up.
I'm rescinding my offer.
I'm out.
Okay.
You have an offer
on the table.
So far, I have not heard
any others.
The only other was retracted
'cause Daymond's
in a nasty mood today.
I'm gonna make an offer.
Let's hear it.
I trust you, but I don't trust
the product enough.
Okay.
So I'll give you half
for 40% of your business.
But Daymond has got to come
back in with me,
putting up half of the $90,000
and I the other half.
He's a great partner for you.
And I want 10 cents
for every Pillow you sell.
Ooh!
Royalty.
Even worse.
Call it what you want.
Let's call it a royalty.
(laughs)
But you have to admit,
it's a very high-Risk business.
I don't agree with that.
We've launched this company
with $10,000
and were profitable
within the first few weeks.
And I've done this before--
If Barbara wants that deal,
I'm willing to entertain
that deal.
I already have a luggage line
with travelpro.
I could put this right into
that system and obv--
So, Daymond, you're willing
to partner with me?
I'm willing to partner with you,
but we need that answer now
before this drags out
and the prices go up.
W-We came in here
and wanting to do a deal.
I--And, Daymond, of course
we were thinking about you
'cause of your experience
in the textile industry.
But for giving up 40%
of the company
and then you have
two partners here...
let me make it
more interesting.
I am willing to put Daymond
in on my deal
and throw Barbara
under the bus.
I don't want this
to get too crazy.
I'm still
with Barbara on it,
because there wouldn't be
enough meat for Barbara and I
or Kevin and I to work
at a lower percentage.
Are you declining the offer
for $90,000?
Both Barbara and I will
be in for 40%.
I think that's too high
of a share of the company.
We've done $60,000 in goods.
I would do the same deal
if it's--if it's...
don't do it.
30%.
(Kevin)
my deal's very simple.
It's $90,000 for 33 1/3%.
We're 3-Way partners.
And we all get paid
at the same time,
which is very reasonable.
Daymond's and my deal
is $90,000 cash for 40%,
and we get 10 cents
on every Pillow that you sell.
Barbara and Daymond, can you do
that same deal at 30%?
Don't do it. You guys are crazy
if you do that deal.
If we went halfway and met you
right in the middle--35%--
Would you come the other half?
Rebecca, you obviously have
a number in mind.
Why are we skating around it?
What's your number?
20% for $90,000.
Okay. So we've heard
from both of you. I'm out.
Why are you out?
Because they don't want
to meet us halfway.
You won't accept the 40%.
You won't accept 35%.
(Robert) Rebecca, let me make it
very simple.
I'll give you the $90,000
for 20%.
I missed out on you once.
Mm-hmm.
I'm not gonna do it again.
I think you're gonna
make it happen.
Wow.
That's a full-price offer.
Why would you even hesitate?
I'm looking at
the majority shareholder.
I have--He has to make
that decision.
Robert, you have a deal.
Very good.
Damn.
(Robert) Excellent.
Thank you.
Yeah, thanks. Nice to be
in business with you this time.
Thank you. Thanks, you guys.
Whoo! Thanks!
Very Good. Thank you.
Good luck to you.
(Robert) Well...
you sneaky guy, you.
(laughs)
I'll tell you something.
That lady--She's gonna
make it happen.
I don't like her.
I don't care if you like her.
You like her when
she's on your side.
I feel so excited to come back
in "Shark tank" Again
and walk away
with another deal.
And Robert is gonna be
a great partner for us.